Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
Chaque adulte
souhaite le bonheur des enfants,
qu’ils soient eux-mêmes,
qu’ils aient confiance en eux,
qu’ils enthousiasment, qu’ils jouent
et rient beaucoup.
Il y a cependant
des statistiques angoissantes
et de gros paradoxes.
À l’école, un enfant sur dix
subit du harcèlement.
Le suicide constitue la deuxième cause
de mortalité chez les jeunes.
Les dangers du Web sont connus
et pourtant, 80% des sept-douze ans
regardent des vidéos tout seul.
Les enfants sont éduqués
pour bien se comporter à l’extérieur,
« Soit poli, soit sage. »
Mais ils ne connaissent pas toujours
l’existence de leur pouvoir intérieur.
Les parents s’efforcent
d’être de bons parents,
mais ce n’est pas si facile.
J’ai fait partie de ces personnes
prises dans l’engrenage du mal-être.
La femme qui travaillait trop
dans le tourbillon
du monde de la communication,
la maman qui faisait de son mieux.
J’aurais apprécié avoir toujours
la disponibilité pour jouer,
me détendre et être partout à la fois.
Convaincue d’avoir une vie plutôt pas mal,
j’avançais en fait, en mode robot,
en mode survie.
Petit à petit,
comme vous vous en doutez,
je me suis vidée, éteinte et écroulée.
Quand les parents vivent à 1000 à l’heure,
les enfants suivent sans faire de pause,
sans souffler.
Tout le monde finit fatigué.
Les familles éclatées paraissent
moins propices à une enfance légère,
insouciante, sécurisante.
Les écrans omniprésents
remplacent la curiosité,
la nature, les jeux, les histoires.
Ils génèrent agitation et agressivité.
Et les enfants grandissent vite.
À douze ans, ils sont déjà adolescents
et fragiles psychologiquement.
Les parents sont censés représenter
des modèles guidant et soutenant.
Au final, trop souvent,
le message éducatif se floute
alors que les enfants
ont tant besoin de clarté,
de direction et de sérénité
pour relever les défis
de notre société en pleine mutation.
Et si on se réveillait ?
Et si on agissait ?
Et si on inversait la tendance ?
Et si on guidait vraiment les enfants ?
À 34 ans, j’ai tout bouleversé.
J’ai vécu les quatre D :
divorce,
démission,
déménagement,
dépression.
Vivre le chaos
d’une maman solo au chômage,
épuisée émotionnellement,
malade de surcroît.
Toutefois, je suis restée profondément
rêveuse et optimiste.
Imaginez un environnement plus doux
où l'amour et la paix rayonnent.
J'étais tellement persuadée qu'il existait
que j'ai réussi à le trouver.
Pour cela, il m'a fallu passer à l'action,
réfléchir à quel chemin emprunter.
J'ai entamé une quête de sens,
une quête de vrai.
L’Univers du développement personnel
s’est manifesté devant moi
et j’ai adoré mes découvertes.
Prendre du temps pour soi,
apprendre à s’aimer,
décrypter le langage de son corps,
écouter la voix de son cœur,
vider de sa tête les boucles des pensées.
Ressentir, rire,
pleurer, remercier.
Transformer ses blessures passées
en expériences précieuses.
Faire preuve de résilience
et sortir de sa zone de confort.
Se détacher de sa culpabilité.
Cultiver son authenticité.
Accepter son hypersensibilité.
Être fort à l’intérieur
pour rayonner à l’extérieur.
Un tel parcours de travail sur soi
est toujours semé d'embûches.
Tout n’est pas agréable, loin de là.
Un jour, je me suis dit :
« Si seulement j’avais appris
toutes ces ressources avant,
quand j’étais enfant. »
Alors, j'ai entrainé ma grande fille
dans cette joyeuse aventure.
Et puis ma petite fille,
en intégrant dans notre quotidien
des rituels bien-être
qui font beaucoup de bien.
Cinq attitudes ont transformé notre vie
et pourraient vous inspirer
en tant que parents
ou futurs parents ou grands parents.
Première attitude :
accueillir et exprimer ses émotions.
J'ai décidé de commencer par mes émotions.
Aperçu d’une scène chez nous :
« Les filles,
là, je me sens hyper énervée.
Je me soupçonne d’exploser bientôt.
Je vais tenter de me calmer
dans ma chambre.
J'ai besoin de tranquillité
s'il vous plait.
Après, on pourra passer
un moment ensemble.
Ou pas. »
Avoir sa bulle pour soi,
son cocon refuge,
c’est indispensable pour décharger
ses tensions et se recharger en énergie.
Deuxième attitude :
mettre en place
des routines plaisantes et efficaces.
Mes filles ont pris l’habitude
de pratiquer la posture de l’arbre,
en yoga,
pour favoriser leur concentration
avant les devoirs.
Elles utilisent également
des techniques de relaxation
pour faciliter leur endormissement.
Développer sa confiance en soi
s’apprend encore mieux de manière ludique.
Troisième attitude :
privilégier écoute et empathie.
Quelle fierté, quand ma petite me dit :
« Maman, je crois que ma grande sœur
a de la tristesse toute bleue
dans son cœur,
je vais lui prêter ton doudou chat. »
L’empathie aide les enfants à développer
des habiletés sociales
et crée de la complicité.
Au Danemark,
des cours d’empathie sont obligatoires
dans les écoles depuis 1993.
Quatrième attitude :
faire des pauses.
Je vous livre mon secret.
Je prends rendez-vous avec moi-même.
Pour ancrer cette habitude,
j’ai retenu les heures miroirs :
14 h 14, 20 h 20,
qui sont source d’harmonie et d’équilibre.
J’alterne pour ces pauses
entre respiration,
auto-massage,
connexion à mon enfant intérieur,
écriture.
Les enfants intègrent
les choses par imitation.
Un enfant qui voit ses parents
faire des pauses
aura naturellement envie
de faire pareil.
Cinquième et dernière attitude :
pratiquer la gratitude.
À la maison, tous les soirs, à table,
nous partageons tendrement
ce que nous avons aimé dans notre journée.
D’un fou rire avec des amis
au parfum d’une bougie à l’amande,
en passant par un délicieux cookie
aux pépites de chocolat.
La gratitude possède
des bienfaits incroyables
et procure une sensation
immédiate d’émerveillement,
qu’on soit enfant, ado ou adulte.
J’espère que ces cinq clés
auront retenu votre attention.
J’ai continué mes expérimentations
familiales avec mon entourage
dans des ateliers informels
pour les enfants,
avec un message porteur de bien-être,
d’éveil des consciences
et l’envie furieuse
de rendre les enfants heureux.
J’ai alors remarqué que sans le savoir,
je m’inscrivais dans une révolution
profonde en matière d’éducation
et déjà bien en mouvement.
Celle-ci se fonde d’une part
sur la remise en question
des systèmes éducatifs d’antan
et sur les dernières recherches
des neurosciences
sur le fonctionnement
du cerveau des enfants.
Vous avez certainement
entendu parler de l’ocytocine,
l’hormone de l’amour et du plaisir.
Saviez-vous qu’un câlin de 20 secondes
permet de libérer suffisamment
d’ocytocine
pour contrer les effets
du cortisol, l’hormone du stress ?
Je vous invite vivement à tester
pour percevoir la douceur
qui monte en vous.
L’ocytocine, c’est l’hormone
de l’attachement,
produite entre autres à la naissance
et pendant l’allaitement.
C'est la matérialisation chimique
du lien affectif.
Cette révolution se fonde d’autre part
sur les pédagogies alternatives observées
notamment dans les pays scandinaves,
qui considèrent l’estime de soi
comme un pilier essentiel.
C’est pourquoi les entreprises
capitalisent désormais
sur les compétences
dites comportementales.
Les choses avancent et dans le bon sens,
puisque ce réenchantement
commence dès l’enfance.
J’ai donc décidé d’aller plus loin.
Dans mon appartement,
sans formation spécifique,
sans argent, en pyjama,
portée par mon élan de maman heureuse,
j’ai créé intuitivement tout un concept
d’atelier bien-être pour les enfants
Dans ces ateliers à l’approche globale,
les enfants apprennent
à prendre soin d’eux,
à ralentir, à se connecter
à l’instant présent avec leur tête,
leur corps et leur cœur.
Ils découvrent des outils concrets,
adaptés en fonction de l’âge
et des besoins,
météo des émotions,
jeux coopératifs,
cercles de parole,
pratique corporelle,
dessin.
En l’espace de six ans,
ma pratique personnelle
s’est développée
au point d’en faire mon métier.
600 femmes et hommes sont acteurs
de ce mouvement
pour le bonheur des enfants
et rayonnent sur les cinq continents.
Grâce à eux, 60 000 enfants
ont participé à ces ateliers.
Le succès s’est fait
par le bouche-à-oreille.
Des enfants bien dans leurs baskets
valent mieux
que toutes les agences de communication.
Deux cas très concrets
illustrent mon propos.
D’abord, Rose, six ans et demi,
très important « et demi »,
porteuse d'une maladie génétique.
Rose est souvent fatiguée,
bien plus que les autres enfants,
et elle fréquente les hôpitaux.
On dit d'elle qu'elle a une certaine
intolérance à la frustration.
Elle peut faire preuve de méchanceté,
ce qui complexifie ses relations sociales.
Maintenant, tous les matins, au réveil,
Rose s'étire comme une étoile de mer.
Elle démarre sa journée du bon pied
en se chuchotant et en s'amusant.
Et tous les soirs,
sa maman lui fait un long câlin
pour libérer la fameuse ocytocine
et remplir son réservoir d’amour
de paix et de gentillesse.
Au fur et à mesure, Rose s’adoucit
tant vis-à-vis d’elle-même
que vis à vis des autres.
Océane, treize ans.
Au collège,
elle a été victime de harcèlement
et elle a sombré
dans l’anorexie et l’automutilation.
Plusieurs éléments ont été combinés
pour la réconcilier avec son corps.
La solution qu’elle a préférée,
c’est la conception de Super Océane,
une superhéroïne imaginaire,
déterminée, bien dans sa peau.
Océane l’a visualisée, dessinée
et lui a révélé ses tourments.
Aujourd'hui, elle va bien.
Elle mange avec motivation
une grosse assiette de coquillettes
avant ses compétitions d’athlétisme.
Elle sait qui elle est et elle sait
que Super Océane veille sur elle.
Que serait devenue Océane sans ce dessin ?
Tous ces rituels bien-être
donnent du baume au cœur
et aident à affronter
les difficultés de l’existence.
Ils fonctionnent pour les enfants,
évidemment, mais aussi pour les adultes,
grands enfants qu'ils sont.
Rose et Océane comptent
particulièrement pour moi
et dans ma vision professionnelle,
parce qu’il s’agit
de l’histoire de mes filles.
Ma contribution pour notre nouveau monde,
c’est d’offrir la possibilité,
dès l’enfance,
d’accéder à des ressources bien-être
comme l’expression des émotions,
la mise en place de routines,
le développement de l’empathie,
l’art de faire des pauses
et la pratique de la gratitude.
J’ai la conviction que grâce à ces
réflexes simples et ludiques,
les enfants se sentent apaisés,
autonomes, forts et épanouis.
Avant, les enfants travaillaient
et recevaient des coups de martinet.
Ensuite, on les a envoyés
à l’école et punis au coin.
Hier, des lois ont été votées contre
les violences éducatives ordinaires.
Pour demain,
mon rêve, c’est que tous les enfants
disposent d’outils de développement
personnel pour être heureux
et devenir plus tard des adultes heureux.
Parce qu’il me semble évident
qu’élever un enfant fort
est plus facile que réparer
un adulte brisé.
Merci du fond du cœur.